。
嗯。
我们说这部电影首先啊我们来先先细说一下这部电影小品型的电影。
爆米花电影你必须用得到，就这种电影你如果不会写那就完犊子了啊。这部电影必须学会怎么写，因为这是标非常标准的old school啊，我们说这就是标准的old school啊，这种这种类型你日常写个小品啊，写个这个这个段子都用得上啊，这种模型都用得上。
标准的啊何庆奎老师的手笔啊何庆奎老师的手笔。
来。
我们直接上课啊，说一下这部电影，选这部电影。当然了嗯看一看赵老师，看一看宋丹丹老师这这这两个老师我估计将来也都不太会再主演电影了，对吧？基本都属于退休状态。中国算是最好的几个演员对吧？在这部电影里面直接凑了俩去去欣赏一下这个演技啊，包括村长。
啊，包括懒汉这个呃梁野啊就是。
呃，演技是相当的自然啊，那个时代的演员确实。
基本功非常扎实啊非常。
说一下这部电影干啥呢？嗯，非常简单，这一部电影80分钟啊，我没有说本山大叔身体不好的啊，我是说他们已经半退休状态，不太愿意演了。我是这个意思啊，没有说呃两位老师身体不好，我只是说以他们的江湖段位呢，现在其实已经开始减少抛头露面了。
啊，第一拍第一分钟先交代环境啊，一个小山村。然后呢，宋丹丹用宋丹丹寻找男主这个这种方式带着观众了解一下环境。我们说这第一拍交代环境啊，第二拍直接主角登场？我们说第一拍为什么没用主角登场呢？是因为这个宋丹丹老师也是。
非常大的腕啊。所以说你你得考虑你手里有什么牌，什么演员，你去怎么摆你的戏的情况啊。所以说这部戏主角没有在第一场环境里面登场。第二拍第三分钟这里啊主角带着技能登场，他有个什么技能啊？
用一场小小的误会戏啊，小小的钻地窖，跟跟漂亮小媳妇儿钻地窖的呃这么一场误会戏，主角带着技能登场，因为环境里面没灯了啊，主角什么技能啊？
擅长帮助妇女嘛？能干活，那是肯定的。但是在这部故事，在这个电影里面，主角的技能是善于帮助妇女。
那个宋丹丹都用台词说了嘛，对，他是父女之有，然后呢呃这个乐于助人救猫咪对吧？叫啥？呃，顺便和老婆的感情线这个这个稍微稍微铺了一下。因为老婆老婆的感情线是故事大高潮啊，呃我们后面会会讲到嗯因为。
呃，这个电影他讲的是一个假妇女主任到真妇女主任的一个弄假成真型的类型啊。同学们记住这种故事类型以后统称弄假成真。
这节课必须把这种结构给我学会，得啊。我其实以前讲过很多这种类型的电影，我思来想去用这部电影跟大家去学呃让大家学同类型的电影。我们说摇滚校园和定制伴郎自己记一下梦嫁成人型啊这个。
定制伴郎，当然它不是一个大类型啊，嗯，但是这种类型你一定用得到啊，弄假成真这种类型啊。来到第三拍第5分钟啊，啊在争吵中把剧情往前推一推。嗯妇女主任来召唤了啊，妇女主任来召唤了，拒绝召唤。我们说第三拍来到第五分钟啊，嗯，我们说主角得到了任务的召唤，就妇女主任。
开啥妇女会呀，我然后来到第四part啊，第七分钟行啊暂时接过了开会这个任务啊，暂时接过这个任务。现在吧我跟你说第五拍第9分钟连夜写材料啊，包括各种伏笔啊、笑点呀，甚至还有一场裸戏是吧？第五拍还有一场裸戏。第六拍来到了11分钟，然后呃正式去开会。
然后呢很有仪式感啊，这个背景音乐非常欢快啊，我们觉那场戏拍的很美好，美东北一带秋天啊，怎么还不走呢？然后第七拍14分钟开会的时候取得了大的成功啊。
然后第八拍18分钟啊，喝醉酒回来了呃，闯祸了呃神奇的演技啊，看一下机这是第18分钟啊哪喝的？
喝回来了啊。
。
轻点，还亮。
汽水有人吗？
转场也太差了。
是啊李本回来了，那啥，你叫他马上到村委会来，他还喝多了，其实这会喝多了。你看这些演员的演技多好哎呀，这个多自然。你喝酒了，对吧？而不是他好像很容意我这个我为什么老笑话人家，怪不得孙说呢，怎们的也能喝完水。
这边人乡了一半喝多了，我自热喝混酒喝清点喝的啥也没道啊？全红酒对那汽水油呢冰块对哎，你看我脸红红酒吗？开完会感觉挺冲的。
见着谁，我都陪了你谁把书包给我。
书包这场面，我跟你说，你一生你都看不着哎呀。
我这边是一个孙县女的，可能咱村长也没机会见他，这边人相了一把手，会开的不错呗，不是不错，喝的啥，你知道不？全红说你的发言对强烈的反响不是强烈呵。
哎，你看我脸红很红酒吗？开完会感觉挺，挺整啊哈，还整出个什么接着谁，我的就姨还有谁是。
书包这家伙咋写，我这一种发言卡把咱眼。
如果说这次不你成功，感谢你给我那些材料，全来了，我全用上了，我让你审，你还不审呢。
会开的不错会了之后，我跟你说，那场面大不错，专门很不错。陪孙院长听说你的发言引起了强烈的反响，不是强烈看不着这场面。
你都在人。
以后你能整任何重大会议还整出个什么54321还有我就上那去一切我这一种发言咱刺激完了，干啥呢？如果说这次会议成功，感谢你给我那些材料。
受了，我受刺激让你开个会，你老事在这着听得了呗，话演讲专门他手里又是12345又543又是宣传啊，又是工8千一点，你。
以后乡里还有任何重大会议，拿们了吗？多有次激，你告诉我明白，我就你让那去完事，一切切都是我给你办去证完哎。
这的。
神一样的演技神一样的演技啊，就这种戏真的是。
塑造这类角色真的是全国没有人比赵老师更厉害啊。当然范伟老师塑造角色的宽度更宽啊。呃，确实村长这部戏里面集合了干啥呢？几个非常牛牛的演员啊，非常牛的演员，这是俺家一本然后故事来到第九拍22分钟。
他惹事儿了，意识到自己惹惹事了，也没有退路了，只能硬着头皮上正式开始啊进入征程。第一幕就作。第二幕从第十拍24分钟开始进入第一次战役。因为这个故事它的结构非常清楚啊，第一次战役就是贴标语来了。
正式进入贴标语战役，但是在第十拍正式开始贴标语这场战役的时候就已经垫上了。
第11拍27分钟开始管妇女的闲事，他管的第一个妇女的闲事儿，当然是帮人修胎教啊。在这里就他正式当上假妇女主任之后，他管的第一个闲闲事还是那个那个妇女呃，就是演技略微漂浮的那个第12拍来到第2029分钟啊。
和老婆意见。
不一啊，后院摆不平。我们说他跟老婆的感情线，由于这个故事啊是一个小品级别的故事，所以说他的体量不大。嗯，他必须垫上这个老婆这个29拍啊，跟老婆这个意见不合，我们来看一下吧，正好顺便欣赏一下宋丹丹老师的演技。一教小孩子，你就。
就降糊了。
我去。
别生气了嗯。
不是的。
你还叫我啥？
伸手打人，我我我打不过你。
货是我惹的，我惹我为啥惹的祸？
人村长那么信任咱们那么重要的会议，让咱们去开，咱们给人到那吹吹吹吹出毛病来了。你说要不然人家也下来了。
那这回咱能对得起人家吗？
办事啊得有人情，你懂不？你。
啊，不多看了啊，但就是他这个戏啊，其实严格说啊，他的戏确实是比较舞台化。可能当时就是有可能是大学刚毕业啊，还停留在舞台感的东西比较重。因为生活当中是这样啊，就生活当中你看赵本山老师孙丹老师，他们就是这种生活派的呃演法。
啊，生活派的研发就是嗯比较先入戏啊，先入戏。你相信你自己是这个角色，你做的一切动作都是对的。
但像这个女演员啊，他就是在用表演方法在演。比如说他认为呃呃故事当中的呃角色，这个宋丹丹和赵本山人家两夫妻产生矛盾了。然后呢，他又是一个邻居啊在这儿暂时先待着帮忙。
所以他那种局促啊他那种。
那种他就认为他应该用东张西望的动作来演啊，嫂子啊，别生气了。
我来吧是吧，然后就碎的动作很多，就碎的动作很多，你知道吧？就是表演不精准，就很碎。这种东西啊，在舞台上那种是可以用的对吧？嫂子啊，别生气了，是吧？这种这这是在舞台上是可以用的，但是就是在这个戏里面确实就是搭不上啊。
我没有任何笑话人家的意思啊，客观啊客观讨论演员还是长得很漂亮啊，很有魅力。为什么说要专门看一下这29分钟第12拍，这里和老婆意见不统一呢？我们可以提前预告一下啊，他的任务是什么？我们说整个故事的主线是什么？
整个故事的主线是当妇女主任，就是做好妇女工作嘛。那么它有几个层次。第一个层次是当假妇女主任，也就是造假，然后来应付检查。所以说他的第一层次是造假。第二幕是做假妇女主任。那么进到第三幕之后，他就要开始做。
什么弄假成真型的故事，从故事终点开始，后面就要做真妇女主任。那真妇女主任就不就不是应付检查了呀，是要解决妇女的各种问题，对吧？。但是我们说如果一个故事。
如果一件一个护事，我们说本来是做假妇女主任，后来是做真妇女主人，那就真成了一个小品了，对吧？层次太少了，未来还有第三层就是你忽视了你生命中最重要的一个妇女谁呀第一块假妇女主人。第2块，真妇女主人，开始真的关心妇女，对吧？？
最后一块再来一个小小的包袱，再起一个小小的高潮。你你生命中就有一个非常重要的妇女啊，对吧？这这这个凤连嘛，对吧？然后然后再去摆平它是吧？三个层次。我们说这种电影啊，三层就比较漂亮了啊，两层的话就就真的就成小品了啊。
先先预告一下，为什么我们说前面一直要铺，跟他老婆经常要吵架是有用的啊是有用十三拍32分钟啊呃，检查团没来，第一次战斗失败，14拍35分钟，第二次战斗文艺慧演。我们说第二次战斗文艺演出啊，花钱请二人转。
然后第15拍呢，36分钟积极准备这个二人转啊，还准备了羊汤，演出也非常热烈，结果检查团又没来，又没来啊，16拍42分钟，嗯，赵本山呢觉得这样不是办法，想争取大家的配合支持啊嗯这个但是彻底失败了，什么失败了？造假失败了。
我们说42分钟是标准的故事终点，菜造假生涯失败，你这不坑人的吗？不来了，造假生涯失败，从们看见呢？他们要不来呀，咱自个儿吃啊，来咱来都来上菜自己吃，咱自己吃吧，自己吃好的刚刚那菜我就尝，在这里。
吃这顿饭。
说着啊，你几个别着马又说啥呀？
我想跟全体妇女说几句，还说啥呀，啥也别说了，我认了哎，处长，大伙辛苦了啊。村饭准备好了，吃完饭再走你吧，好吧？着不就12345嘛？我再想办法不就完了。那我想办法今天这个文化活动就到这儿啊。
男同志可以回家了，父女要留下来，我有点事要说啊，别走啊。
喂。
故事终点啊，这场戏拍的略显浮夸啊，与这个与这个片子整体气质不太搭。90年代可以理解啊。
我们说来这雅戏表示什么呢？表示你真心对待的那些人还是站在你这一面的。当然这里是虚假的失败，对吧？你作假你一直在作假，你凭什么让妇女听你的，你本身就是个假的，但是谁支持你呢？就是你真心帮助过的这几些人是帮助你的，对不对？真心帮你的人是。
呃，你真心关心的人是帮你的，你看就开启故事第三幕啊。
故事开始第三部。
第46分钟。
新的方法，那我们就真的前面是玩假的，从46分钟第七拍开始呃第1七拍开始玩真的啊，玩真的。
玩真的是什么？咱自己排节目吗？为什么要造假呢？咱自己演节目呗，自己搞活动呗，对不对？然后第18拍50分钟，为了达到新的目标，他悟到了一个新的方法，需要团结，需要化解危机，也就是需要去团结大家，关心大家1九拍来到52分钟，帮吵架的夫妻看孩子。
是吧这是他帮助大家的开始帮助大家嘛，组织大家排节目发动群众，20拍53分钟，个个击破村长呀、老太太呀，个个去击破然后21拍56分钟又去帮女二家干活，帮那个懒汉家里干活，换取他来唱二人转，各个关心各个帮助嘛。
22拍59分钟，让帮一帮那个妇女呃洗衣服，让他们唱三句吧。在这里呢老婆彻底发飙啊，我们说老婆这条感情线一直在阻碍他，就是因为后面是有大用的啊，所以说在这里帮一帮老娘们洗衣服呢，老婆发飙了啊，张哥说好了，讲点信誉。23分钟61拍。
老婆惩罚惩罚主角洗衣服，然后那些唱三句班的那几个妇女呢，反过来帮她。我们说这是一场重要的戏，表示她的付出有回报了。
他的付出有回报了，24拍63分钟，孩子丢了。
做了一个危急，孩子丢了啊，全村一起找孩子。这场戏你们你们圈一下，我们待会儿可以讨论一下这场戏有没有用。
它不是主线上的事情，对吧？啊也算是主线事上上主线上的事情吧，帮妇女看孩子嘛。
来25拍。
65分钟啊，25拍65分钟，检查他不来了。
啊，不来也照常工作，真正的做到了甄书记主任，真正做到了要做妇女工作啊，这是第四幕的第一场检查团又不来了，但是不要紧，我们还是要过我们的妇女生活啥玩意第26拍67分钟跟你一老婆正式发飙啊，正式发飙。
嗯，感情线解决呃，解决最后一个妇女问题啊，解决最后一个妇女问题。
27拍70分钟，为了让大家都来参加晚上的活动啊，再次用羊去骗大家，就骗大家喝羊汤，但最后把羊放跑了，？大家看一下已经进到第四幕了，又退回去用欺骗的手法好不好？
这场戏位置记一下啊，27拍都已经进到第四幕了，片子马上就要结束了，依然用欺骗的方法解决问题，这个位置不好。
这里处理有点草率了啊处理有点草率了，大家去思考一下，28拍72分钟，用羊片大家来啊，应该放在中前部。这里已经烘托，获取妇女支持了啊。来整了28拍72分钟我家好活动现场啊，非常热闹啊。
但是检查结结果检查团没来啊，把羊放跑了。
29拍77分钟搞活动，这次是真的沙牙，真的开洋场啊，真的沙牙。29拍是真的沙牙了。77分钟，最后一拍30分钟30拍，最后一拍啊，79分钟，检查团最终也没有来啊，但是演出大获成功啊，姐妹们呃水了差不多5分钟的时长唱二人转啊。
用二人转的方式点题。当然了，这也是赵老师嗯的影视作品当中水时长的常用手法啊，经常唱个电视剧更夸张啊，经常一唱唱个15分钟。
水水时长啊，唱一段王二姐似乎七分半没了，在这个电影里面还是还可以吧啊，我们说有两个东西啊，就是关于帮助妇女第三幕啊啊其实有点少啊，关于怎么样真正的帮助妇女。第三幕其实有点少。总体上来看，然后呢那个危机啊不是特别好，就小孩丢的这个危机不是特别好。
因为也不适合放大，对吧？放大呢也没什么意思，不放大呢，这个危机就放在那儿了，不是特别好。我如果是咱们现在重新复盘，重新去改啊，实际上危机还是放在他老婆身上比较好啊，放在宋丹丹身上比较好。这样的话这个宋丹丹这戏份可以拉起来，否则在整个电影里面这个。
太工具人了啊，有几个位置确实是可以再商讨啊，就一是大危机，二是那个用羊骗，最后最后呢还还用羊再骗一把啊，还耍一个这种戏，实际上也没有必要。另外呢就是帮助妇女产生转变啊，太草率了啊，基本上都是蒙太奇。
帮人家掰苞米呀，帮人家洗衣服呀，就获取了他家的大家的支持。这个位置有点少啊，就这这些都是可以商讨的。但总而言之啊，我们说这种弄假成真类型的故事啊，我推荐大家去看一下摇滚校园呀、定制伴郎呀，这种这种类型啊。
它的结构一般是什么样的啊，被迫去干一件假的事情，开始呢用蒙骗的手段对吧？尝到一些甜头，但是带来了失败。然后故事终点之后，开始真的做这件事情，然后获奖获到的成功明白我的说什么？开始用蒙骗的手段做假。
后面开始真的做这件事情，反而获取了不是这么说的这种这种类型都知道一定要学会，因为太常用了。哎呦这种类型的故事真的先天性的适合写小品。下面请看二人转。同学们有没有看过呃这个赵本山老师和高秀敏老师，还有范伟老师演的那个拜年。
是叫这叫拜年还是老拜年，应该也是何庆奎老师的手笔啊，大家花花个十几分钟时间可以去看一下那个小品，好不好？
那个小品啊就是从香港一下变成三胖子了啊，确实是这个结构一看就是何庆奎老师的手笔啊，弄假成真。我们说哎咱们说一句。
葛老师是非常优秀的作者啊，创作者来，但是绝对一招先吃遍天，所以说你要你一定要学会写这种类型啊，在商鱼片里面，在舞台表演里面，在小品里面都是非常吃香的啊，上来先作假。
最后再弄成真的啊，然后第三再来一个小的转小的那个反转啊，后沟沟。这个故事就是我先做假妇女主人是吧？再做真妇女主人，然后最后呢再摆平自己最重要的人生妇女哎，三段诗写个小品播号。
吧写个电影确实需要水点时长啊，一共就七十来分钟，唱戏就有10分钟。然后这个故事啊给大家思考一些问题吧，就是关于那个危机的位置啊，好不好？以及那个呃感情破裂啊与感情破裂这个爆发啊，需不需要再做的狠一点啊，就是。
和这个同学们我们设想一下啊，如果这个电影是好莱坞血，那这个邻居家的这个懒汉媳妇儿啊。
可能就是。
给这个给主角家里带来的危机要更大。当然啦，肯定不会写有一腿啊。
但是带来的危机带来的误会要更大。明白我在说什么吗？我们如果单纯的从商业性的角度。
不考虑谁来演啊，然后把它放在现在这个情况下，如果要写成一个比较重剧情的故事，我们说她做妇女工作引发的误会啊要更大，难度要更大一些。这部电影由于是个合家欢啊，小品型，所以说还是比较欢乐为主。
同学们通过这种这这个电影啊学会这个类型。另外呢也欣赏一下赵老师然宋丹丹老师的这种演技啊，实际上宋丹丹老师不是东北人，应该是地道北京人啊，还是说认是一直演了一辈子东北人。
挺神奇的。好啊，这就是这部电影啊，希望同学们去扩展阅读一下嗯小品老伴年啊，拜年，以及嗯我跟大家讲过的摇滚校园啊、定制伴郎呀啊，包括录取通知书啊，大家都去看一下好不好？那咱们今天课就上到这吧。